hello hi hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to quadrant
now we're wandering the hallways now
very much alone because all of our
friends are dead
great oh boy can't wait to see what why
we
you [ __ ]
you're welcome
you're welcome for me dying how is that
comforting in any way oh boy this
episode's up to a great start I've
received a notice from one of my
subordinates
we're in quadrant one he claimed several
rock specimens are unaccounted for and
I've no accounting a research log my
question to you is why was he aware of
these rocks to begin with all
undocumented rocks must be handled in
research explicitly and quadrant three
this research is by no means open all
workers of the facility what would have
happened if he saw the capabilities of
the specimen how they react keep your
workers in order Fletcher all right
thank you I still don't know if I need
to get these fuses so I'm just gonna get
Greg I'm gonna garbin if I can all right
I guess not I really don't know what the
purpose is going into these other rooms
is except to prolong my death great good
admit like this game late I you know I
often play these anymore games and I
don't expect a lot out of them but this
one has been very surprising in that
it's been quite good except like just
the sensitivity is a little high that's
the only thing but I'm pretty sure
that's a scent that's like a setting I
could change the main menu I just
haven't been able to get back to the
main menu yet oh I wonder what horrors
await me in these tunnels of death Marla
Linden
oh that's ah Marla Linden that's another
Foos a closed-open Marla Linden would
say hi to me
Marla Linden I miss you
I don't hear that I don't hear the
crashing or the footsteps anymore I
don't know if that's a good or a bad
thing
okay ow my spine
I hope I'm Kahn's right way oh good
hello I'm here now ok I'll go to
security tape is in five days of birdies
ok alright ok cool oh that's good good
oh good I got a flashlight can I beat
people with it is this my beater weapon
can I please oh yes who needs a
flashlight to see with when you can
smack people in the face who
initializing mmm yes hacking hacking
hacking hacking wait what am i doing
ah I hacked it good I guess did I do it
crap I was wrong on all accounts
hey I got it anyway Oh unlock doors yeah
let's open all the doors so all the
monsters can come kill me oh boy I can't
wait I'm welcome sure I'm glad that I am
do that now let's see what destiny
awaits me in the pizza
another fuse great I still don't know if
I need to pick these up but I got him
nonetheless alrighty then
hello is anybody gonna jump outta me all
the doors are unlocked
I'm totally exposed oh boy it's saved
that's probably not a good sign I jump
over this I can yeah I got a ride right
that's like what's it like okay
oh okay oh okay
oh is this like alien isolation where I
gotta use the vents to hide who threw
that
hmm am I going the right way I really
don't know oh that's my own shadow
literally almost scared me literally
almost literally did that okay wow this
looks fun I'm glad that this is all the
thing good boy okay okay all right okay
okay
okay
good evening
okay all right enough being a big giant
baby even though I'm pretty sure they're
about to introduce the monster very soon
oh oh okay okay all right this was where
that security camera was showing ah that
looks important
key card gained another fuse yes what
another there we go I can't I can't go
there apparently all right I won't then
Thank You invisible wall nothing can get
me if I'm up high okay hello Oh
okay move
I still don't know if the venn is a safe
place you know whole Ozzy's probably
horrible okay okay so this is this where
they threw the cup at me might been come
on hop over it you dingus no no no no no
okay all right so I'm going back now
okay I get it I won one way now I need
to go back I got it okay I'll hit it
back nothing bad will happen
not like you it's still not a good thing
at the fuse get it get what are you
doing what are you doing jumping up and
down and joy oh I was pressing the jump
in but I forgot that the jump on wasn't
pick up button oh these are good sounds
I can't wait okay cool all right cool
that's great
I don't even remember where there was a
keycard door what do I do
oh is this even the right way all this
so not the right way how was this what's
gonna woo what about the place where
there's a big bright light your dingus
Markham ooh oh here we go here we go
here we go okay okay got it got it got
it
oh okay keycard used how do I go up or
down
it's weird it's like the sensitivity
dropped a whole lot okay that's not a
good sound hello hi what are you are you
friendly oh you better be friendly oh
you better be friendly oh you better be
friendly hello
oh it's brighten inviting up here great
is that blood
Oh blood wasn't it God why do I turn so
slow now mine
am I supposed to go in there alright
okay let's not be ridiculous here
Marla Landon oh oh oh oh oh oh okay
oh I shouldn't come back here oh this is
stupid
was a dumb idea okay alright new rock
specimens have been received as of
yesterday over the course of 24 hours
selected samples have shown an increase
in size approximately 15 percent exposed
to terrestrial air okay magnetic
attributes okay cool
these rocks are made of magic see
telekinetic abilities flung various
objects placed around them great why
I've gotten word from researchers in
quadrant three the specimens are showing
signs of life great wonderful can they
kill us movement awareness even partial
understanding they're learning will what
we found what humanity is found will
change the way we view the universe
forever such a huge stride for humankind
was inevitable we've been looking for so
long
here's what we've been searching for the
first signs of an intelligent
extraterrestrial life and they can kill
us whoo whoo whoo you're supposed to go
down this way oh here we go into the
vent okay
of course of course of course nice and
slow it's not okay that's not okay
that's not okay hello hello hi oh don't
do that don't do that don't do that
don't do that don't do that okay so far
I have jumped out of my skin at nothing
we have continued interaction with our
working samples awareness is now present
various specimen life is undeniable
we've continued to categorize each
specimen by shape and limb count however
we have not been able to clearly define
size as sample continues its growth
several the hexa patil and quadra patil
species show sluggish but perceptive
awareness is our belief that the
subjects are rapidly adapting to our
terrestrial atmosphere we expect
communication to be reality within
several days okay hi how's it going over
here
great who's here who's gonna kill me
anybody great what did I just pick up I
have no idea maybe like a cassette or
something oh okay I think that was the
first glimmer of what the monster who
told me that who gave me that objective
oh my god am i making my own objectives
now I can't believe it I've grown
intelligence okay so the elevators over
there probably to restore powers over
here somewhere
well the music has gotten interesting
and very interesting I mean holy [ __ ]
was this was this open before oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh no oh no me no likey okay
you know likey okay what is that oh boy
I'm gonna reenact the scene from
Jurassic Park better not make a move
better not get Moy did oh man do I need
here oh great okay okay leg
oh well [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what are you Oh God
[ __ ] me
Oh God [ __ ] you
okay alright holy [ __ ] what's the [ __ ]
this is so weird
oh my god can I go please tell me please
tell me oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
crap oh [ __ ]
hell pulls that ha [ __ ] oh god move move
move move No No please Nev Nev no it's
so foggy in here I can't run anymore I
am dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I can't [ __ ] run oh [ __ ] oh
god what are you doing what are you
doing oh you're ugly Thank You Ellie hi
okay bye alright then cool okay well I
think he bugged out thoughts I think I'm
in luck
hookie cool all right cool
oh good here we go this will work I'll
take it
I'll take it then I got a run in little
fits and bursts okay whoo all right cool
well we met the monster he's a bundle of
joy oh boy here we go
okay all right we're fine okay okay okay
all right okay all right Oh cookie okay
well that ain't good
hey we did it all right I guess
wolf oh man Oh find an exit
Oh God okay so imma that's all for this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the annotation for
more scary games that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
oh boy a robo box cutter are those
rubber hose